Monsoon rains come every year but these
are falling too fast floods in Northern
India are threatening lives and
livelihoods many are already counting
the cost to the agricultural sector and
The Wider economy
there's been a lot of damage the water
swept off Bridges hotels and local
houses at least 72 deaths have been
reported so far since June 21st there's
been a loss of hundreds of thousands of
rupees
parts of India have recorded the
heaviest rainfall on record in decades
the Northern State of Punjab received
double the expected average rainfall
while the Himalayan state of Himachal
Pradesh recorded 10 times its average
in the city of Mundy homes schools and
temples were destroyed by a deluge of
water and mud
[Music]
guy that people my height will drown my
kids are very young all our vehicles are
underwater all our belongings inside are
badly damaged not just us everyone
living in the area is in the same boat
facing the same issues
India has experienced extreme weather
patterns in recent years but this time
around it's particularly severe
scientists say climate change is fueling
the above average rainfall one
environmentalist also blames large
development and road construction
projects that have changed the local
topography you are cutting the mountains
and when you're cutting the mountains
and sometimes rain is bound to happen
that is it that is a climatic situation
that is bound to happen so when it would
happen and you have already cut the
Mountain Water has to follow a natural
course
while India's population of 1.3 billion
people relies on the annual rainfall for
farming too much of it is now causing
Mayhem
Ian Al Jazeera